let's check out this story this is
amazingly from the new york times
will american ideas tear france apart
some of its leaders think so politicians
and prominent intellectuals say
social theories from the us on race
gender and post-colonialism are a threat
to french identity and the french
republic
now that is amazing they say
high-profile intellectuals and
journalists are warning
that progressive american ideas
specifically on race
gender post-colonialism are undermining
their society there's a battle to wage
against an intellectual matrix from
american universities warn mr macron's
education minister
emboldened by these comments prominent
intellectuals have banded together
against what they regard as
contamination by the out of control
woke leftism of american campuses
and attended cancel culture of all of
the countries in europe
that we would point to france is
particularly left
not the like everyone likes to point to
scandinavia but come on the french
revolution
the leftists the socialists the jacobins
i'm not saying that they're the furthest
left but you know they're one of the
examples people cite
especially considering jacobid magazine
is a socialist magazine
and they're stepping up and saying nah
to all this stuff
which is good because in my opinion the
wokeness on the left
is infecting left ideas and turning it
into a weird dogmatic cult ideology that
makes no sense
and i saw the best tweet to explain it
you guys
i want i want to hear your thoughts on
this i saw a really wonderful tweet
breaking down
like gender ideology they said sexism
is when you say when someone says that
women should be
you know they believe doing the dishes
you know not men
feminism is when the woman comes out and
says both men and women
can be doing the dishes and gender
ideology says
anybody who does the dishes is a woman
you get it
like that's that's pretty like i saw
that and i was like that's that's
actually a good example
of like what's happening because you
look at actual
traditional feminism and it's like women
and men can wear whatever they want
now in the modern era of this critical
theory it's whoever wears feminine
clothes
is a woman and whoever wears masculine
closes a man which is not
doesn't make a whole lot of sense you
know what i mean yeah uh
it's actually kind of interesting and
just because i'm a practicing muslim in
this kind of this
story in france it impacts me in a way
because of obviously the the struggles
that the french
people have had with sort of this rising
threat of islamic terrorism
in the last decade um but with respect
to your point about
you know whoever wears women's clothes
and men's clothes like
i've read obviously in like religious in
islamic
scripture that like a sign of the end of
times is like when you cannot tell the
difference between men and women is that
really in there
yeah it's it's kind of scary in a way uh
again this is like
this is religious stuff if you are if
you subscribe to the islamic faith that
you probably know what i'm talking about
but you know religion obviously isn't
for everyone uh
and it's all based on faith um i mean i
do believe in
a god i do believe that there is a life
after
this one but i'm not gonna be dogmatic
and just preach to you what
is right and what's wrong but with
respect to this uh
st about this sort of you mentioned the
word contagion
that is obviously very fascinating
because for the longest time at least
for the last like century
the red scare has been considered long
held in europe as
like an international contagion this
threat of communism
that is going to jump from one country
to the next
and for it to kind of be turned on its
head and
say that that's coming from the united
states based on
how woke everyone has become uh it's
pretty stunning really yeah the daily
mail had an interesting blurb about this
that i think describes everything that
we're talking about and they said quote
they are arguing that american ideas on
race gender post-colonialism
especially those coming from u.s
universities are undermining
french society and are an attack on
french
heritage i mean that's a pretty bold
statement and of course a lot of people
would agree but a lot of people are even
scared to agree to that because of our
current political climate and to have
france of all countries call it out is
extremely interesting especially with
individuals like emmanuel macron
a former rothschild banker who was
deemed the savior of europe he was
deemed as this superstar the mainstream
media loved him we were there
were you there with me when we were
there for emmanuel macron's uh
kind of celebration the streets were
jam-packed
everywhere everyone loved him then he
came in and then he started
doing austerity measures and then he
started cutting social services are you
sure and then
people were freaked out and that i
covered so many riots in france
if anyone knows how to protest it is the
french people they got crazy they got
intense and we have seen levels of
violence with the yellow vests
that we haven't seen before in in
decades
with the silver and rest unfolded
because of emmanuel macron so to see him
now
say these kind of things that that are
against the establishment is interesting
but also according to the new york times
he's only doing this
because he's trying to court the right
during the next election but that's the
new york times what the new york times
says
is is only weirdly left-wing
it's not economic well it's promoted by
the establishment right promoted by the
mainstream media the same mainstream
media that kind of both
boasted him up and made him as popular
as he is that's that's that's the
contradicting point here that i wanted
to point out
there are a lot of leftists who are
anti-woke there's just not enough
willing to speak out and call it out
but there was uh a shout out to rania
kalik who's a anti-war progressive
who wrote about or made it she made a
video it was really funny probably
really offensive these people called
wokewashing
where it's like you get the military
industrial complex and it's like good
news everybody the ceos of all the
biggest defense contractors are women
we've won it's like no they're blowing
up kids it's okay
it is a woman of color doing it like if
that is the
you know the measure of success we got
serious problems
i was going to say luke uh it
with people celebrating the streets when
macron won and it suddenly dawned on me
that the
2017 french election has so many
parallels to the 2020 election just
because
the candidates involved i mean are you
sure yeah i was just going to ask him
like were people celebrating the streets
because it was marine le pen who wasn't
elected
because that's what it sounds like and
you get someone who's kind of as milk
toast
as you know between biden and macron
yeah
and i think i think that a lot of people
were like yeah i expected biden to suck
i didn't expect him to buy i
i did not expect biden to be this
terrible this quickly well if you look
at the way he was highlighted i mean
there was a lot of controversies
surrounding his banker past
and that was kind of shrugged underneath
the rug and when you were really seeing
him he was seen as an all-star
he was literally praised as the man
who's going to save
europe and people were so angry at him
and so disappointed
there was literal chemical agents and
evacuation plans
made for the paris capital for
government officials because of how
serious the protests got
i can't tell you the level of intensity
i mean i ca i don't even
you know for i got ptsd from what i saw
at the paris protests and i don't even
want to talk about all the gory details
but
some of the most intense street fighting
i have ever seen in my life happened
because of this
outrage against macron a lot of people
are angry with them
so this could be a larger political ploy
i hope not i don't trust macron
but he does bring up good points here
let's be real macron is saying this
people on the left don't view mccrone as
left-wing you know he's a bankster
he's a he's far right he's a nationalist
all of those things
so they viewed you know him it's
you know i guess what the problem is
left it's similar here with joe biden
they're like oh joe biden's bad
but trump is worse they're like joe
biden's actually a republican
but trump is a fascist and it's like
okay but you know they view mccrone
similarly marine le pen was a fascist
and
you know emmanuel macron is just far
right so they're like it's better i
guess but they'll still protest it
yeah i don't know how they i mean i know
the french elections are like
almost like a jungle primary like in
california they basically get the top
two vote gathers and then they
you know have that runoff i that's the
thing is like the
the overton window in just the
global political spectrum has
shifted so far to the left yet everybody
keeps
backlashing against it and voting people
who are just so far to the right of that
i mean i mean joe biden i've you know
from like the charlie kirks of the world
the trump campaign saying that like
joe biden is actually a trojan horse
horse for
socialism the guy has always been a
corporatist like he's only put
big wall street k street people into
his administration to be fair that is
corporate socialism at the very least
you know the big companies get their
bailouts they get their money printed
for them and then everyone else gets the
crumbs
i'm look when i hear the left complain
about that stuff i'm like you're correct
i agree i think social
social socialism is bad you're mad
they're giving to the corporations
i'm mad about it in general but also
that they're giving to the corporations
and i don't want socialism but i think
we can agree when they they
print money and just give it to you know
transfer the wealth from the people to
the
top you know political elites and
establishment elites that's messed up
yeah i mean just look at these ppp
loans uh you know i love tom brady i
grew up in new england i'm a huge new
england patriots fan
and tom brady is a god amongst men why
the hell is
he his company tb12 getting pvp loans i
mean crazy
i mean i'm fine with companies getting
access to money to pay their employees
just because a company is big doesn't
mean they
probably they probably still have
employees to pay the problem is
that people can't spend money outside of
for the most part in big box stores and
amazon
right and so that's funneling all of the
stimulus and ppp money
back into the hands of major
corporations where they can then
stockpile it if you think that's the
problem wait until you find out about
the military industrial complex
and corporate welfare
not involved but ever got engaged in
politics was because
of the military-industrial complex
particularly the invasion of the iraq
war
i got it i got i got to tell this point
the iraq war i got to tell this funny
joke i just heard
luke you have to ask me a question you
have to ask me what's the most common
french phrase
what's the most common french phrase i
give up
that's it get it it's funny right
are we allowed to make jokes like that
on youtube i would be surprised if we
get banned for that you don't know what
it is
world war one references
i was it was in the movie the monastery
goats they get into a vehicle with like
some russian guys and he's complaining
about the french and he looks over to
his friend and he's like hey what's the
most common french phrase and he leans
over i give up and they all start
laughing
i give up french surrender jokes never
get old right
but to add to the point that you were
saying uh you made a very good point
especially with this wolk culture
because you know the guy who created
mass incarceration and a cop
don't really say you're woke don't
really kind of support you know
they say they support black lives matter
but that's what happens culturally
it's used to divide and conquer us and
then the big institutional powers
push in their kind of puppet
establishment candidates they come in
and then they rule just like they ruled
before
with people thinking that something's
going to change when it's don't joe
biden is literally the institutional
racism they complain about yes
i mean black lives matter endorses the
guy
and then you know 40 days after he gets
elected or not
after gets elected they're like we still
haven't heard from him he's not
amazed that like joe biden
co-sponsored the 1994 crime bill
and hillary clinton gets more flack for
it for saying the word super predator
yeah to this day i just don't understand
it because joe biden
is like fumbly bumbly joe you know no i
mean i get it like
the maybe my favorite ever joe biden
moment
was when he was vice president and
the onion ran the diamond joe biden
series on him just made him look like he
was a
loose cannon you know he had the this is
the big effing deal
all that all that stuff it was funny i
feel like
people just like to gloss over that
stuff but you also luke
you bring up a interesting point about
so like whole the
the adoption of black lives matter um
it's just amazing how so many of these
global corporations and their global
corporations no longer it's no longer
such a thing as
corporate america because these
countries have basically fled the
flood the united states they go to the
countries like china they go to
southeast asia for basically tax
shelters
when it comes to things like black lives
matter
and racial equity or what have you
they rather flock to the chinese
communist party
and get that sweet sweet revenue yeah
like through nike through disney
say that they support like equal justice
for all
and then on the other side of the the
pacific you have the
chinese communist party locking up a
million plus uyghur muslims
just for the crime of practicing their
faith that's true
but uh you know shout out to disney for
giving a thank you to the paramilitary
group that's actually enforcing that
because they helped make mulan
i guess yeah yeah there you go it's that
i mean like
they talk about welcome yeah talk about
i know biden appointed you know the
former disney representative to be the
envoy to china
very fitting so everything works great i
love being lectured you know by all
these politicians corporations
the entertainment industry silicon
valley about racism and injustice when
when it comes to china they're
absolutely silent about it they won't
dare talk about the actual racism and
injustices that happen there
since of course they're you know they
get money from them and that's
crazy well i got to ask you know what is
it
that creates this kind of person who
lines up in lockstep with massive
multinational corporations
the most notorious human rights abusers
to claim they have moral authority over
anybody
it's like the people standing next to
mcdonald's and starbucks and nike are
like
we're morally just and you're the bad
guys you know what it is
it is i mean all politics is
local when you don't have sort of a add
the human element of say for example
say if there are one million americans
who are locked up in the chinese and
in these reeducation camps then
americans might actually care about it
but until that
until that happens these are foreign
distant people we've never heard of them
before
and therefore yeah i would have agreed
with you maybe four or five years ago
but now you've got articles in the
nation where they're like i'm for prison
abolition but i want all of these trump
insurrectionists
right up yeah if they came out and they
were like china has detained one million
trump supporters
people in this country would be like
it's it's tough but you know this this
real threat is important that these
people are are seeking help i mean
they're literally calling for truth and
reconciliation commissions
they've legit been doing it for some
time now and it's only a matter of time
i mean they're gonna start firing people
yeah they're they're slowly like there's
this creep going on
where one day they'll say it's really
bad that you know
this racist person did this thing two
days later they'll say
this it's the most dangerous thing we've
ever seen in our lives then but a week
later they'll say we're literally
facing extinction because of what this
man did like every day
whatever this one thing was they
exaggerated
and they and they so i'll give you an
example the january 6th incident right
with the storming of the capital
it was definitely bad you know these
people stormed in but what they keep
they they've like completely forgotten
or purposefully flubbed over what what
really happened
some people stormed the front fighting
with cops pepper spraying them hitting
them all that bad stuff
and a lot of people walked leisurely
through the doors that were opened by
police
and took selfies with police officers so
that's all forgotten and now all that
anyone remembers of that day
is like a horde of violent
insurrectionists with a plan there was
no plan
people have no idea what they were doing
now they're trying to impeach a
president over it yeah but
my favorite thing is is how aoc turns
that day into she like she fabricates
this story and i mean it she literally
fabricated a story because all that
people remember about the six was the
storming of the capital they ignored the
entire morning of and what happened
so now aoc can claim in the early
afternoon something happened that made
no sense
it's like we forget essentially what
happened on the day
and they gaslight us over and over again
to make it seem worse than it really is
that's like leading to this dramatic
escalation where we could get to a point
we're at a point where they're basically
like we should bring the domestic war
the war on terror home domestically to
go after the trump supporting extremists
there's like um a lack a lack of
critical thinking
or like a short-sightedness i'm not sure
exactly how to phrase it that i think a
lot of people suffer from
i don't really surround myself with
those people i'm used to hanging out
with like people that actually like
think about the past and like
equate that with what's going on and
like make think about it so but i think
a lot of people just are kind of driven
by like
like a lack of memory maybe they don't
have as good of a memory or something
lemmings
well that i mean there are actual
scientific studies that
your memory tends to worsen during a
traumatic event
or at least the correlation between your
memory not being as good that's why
you know when it's so important during
criminal prosecutions and trials that
you have
multiple accounts you can use forensic
evidence to to try to
prove a particular suspect or a
defendant committed a particular crime
because
people's memories are very uh unreliable
now
and i mean we were talking obviously
before the show about aoc's timeline
um you know it's so difficult for people
to
sort of i'd say the biggest folly of all
of that
is that they a lot of journalists were
covering that
did not take a step back to actually
fact check exactly what was going on
then you
just took it at face value not even
conservatives yeah
it took i took so we'll give everyone
the context aoc tells this story and
we've talked about it quite a bit
about you know being in the capital and
fearing for her life i think she was
gonna die because a cop was knocking the
door and she didn't know it was a cop
so everyone just kind of took it to face
value and then michael tracy a
journalist made a comment that she was
manipulative
and that became the news cycle a day
later someone went hey wait a minute she
wasn't even in the capitol building
the story she was telling when she was
in her office and everyone went whoa she
wasn't even at the riot
and then i saw everyone you know even
ben shapiro
were pointing this out saying you know
maybe she was scared but she wasn't even
in the capital
and so i did this tweet and i had a
journalist from huffington post hit me
up saying my timeline was wrong
i was basically saying she was
exaggerating the story because the
evacuation she referenced everybody was
leisurely strolling through the building
like nothing was happening
so her claiming she was fearing for her
life when everyone was fine well i
deleted my tweet
because he told me that i was wrong and
i believed him turns out
he was wrong everybody was wrong aoc's
story about being pinned down in her
in her in a room with someone bang bang
on the door happened a full
hour and 10 minutes before anyone
stormed any building
before the capitals breached so what
happens is
now that it's been a month and most
people have forgotten the timeline of
that day
and they only remember the snippet of
people stormed the capital it was scary
when aoc comes out and says someone
banged on my door it was scary
they instantly just mash that day into
one moment ignoring the timeline of
events
and then you realize aoc fabricated that
story
there's literally no way she thought
quote they got in
when no one had any idea that was going
to happen i was watching the twitter
feeds i was watching the live streams i
was watching trump's speech
and at 1pm i uploaded a video where i
said it's over everyone's going to leave
that's it it's boring nothing's going to
happen literally the exact same time she
thought the world was ending
i was saying it's it's nothing's
happening it's over and then an hour and
ten minutes later
they breached the building so she makes
this stuff up
what's even worse is how you get even
the fact checkers like from snopes
uh then using their gravitas and
authority to
basically in a february third article
uh titled did at aoc exaggerate the
danger she was in during the capital
riot they rank it mostly false
and then they say what's true
ocasio-cortez wasn't in the main capitol
building where the house and senate
chambers are located
but think about that they try to argue
yes they're like she wasn't in the
building
yeah but the people were storming it and
she was scared and i'm like
no that was hour it was over an hour
later
and they didn't evacuate the house
chamber until 2
39 so what a full hour
and what is this it was an hour and 40
minutes later they finally evacuated and
they're claiming she didn't exaggerate
well they did i mean they did say here's
this is why they said what's false
however
ocasio-cortez never claimed to be in the
main capitol building when the attack
on the capital began ocasio-cortez was
as she stated in her congressional
office which is located in the network
of offices and that's not true she
wasn't in her office at the time
she was evacuated at one o'clock before
the storm yeah
what does it say specifically yeah which
is located in the netherlands
when when the riot happened that's what
it says what is the exact quote
when the attack began on the cap okay
right right and so you could argue that
the breaching of the barricade was an
attack they'll get semantic on you right
they'll move the goal post
but but aoc was evacuated they did give
the all clear at 153 so maybe she went
back to her office
which would be very strange for her
story i was terrified they were to kill
me so i went back to my office as the
right was happening and that's why they
came kicking her door down looking for
her basically they didn't go to her they
never went to her building they're like
open
where is she that was a cop yeah at one
o'clock she didn't report to where she
was supposed to
be no did you ever figure out why yes a
cop was going and telling everybody they
were clearing the building because of a
bomb scare
okay that was according to huffington
post reporter that because there was a
bomb planted at the rnc which is just
right outside longworth
yeah in canon so what made her think
someone knocking on her door was
they got in and this was the end of her
life she had no idea
yeah but that's deep paranoia or she's
just lying
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you